l'iPhone 15 plus c'est un peu un mélange
entre un iPhone 14 pro et de l'autre
côté un iPhone 15 on va donc se donner
un retour aujourd'hui sur l'iPhone 15
plus tout en sachant que ce que je vous
dis sur l'iPhone 15 plus vaut pour
l'iPhone 15 qui est quasiment le même
modèle à deux petites différences prê la
première c'est la taille de l'écran sur
l'iPhone 15 vous avez un écran de 6,1
pouces sur l'iPhone 15 plus vous avez un
écran de 6,7 pouces c'est la diago
au-delà de ça c'est quasiment la même
chose autre différence a la taille de la
batterie mais une fois de plus c'est
tout et rien d'autre ce sont deux
smartphones qui sont extrêmement
similaires l'iPhone 15 plus on va
commencer par le tarif directement parce
qu'il faut tout remettre un peu en
perspective l'iPhone 15 plus est dispo à
partir de 1119 € l'iPhone 15 969 € ça
reste un certain budget mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que cette année Apple
n'a pas augmenté ses tarif a plutôt
tendance à diminuer plutôt bien en
période d'inflation et si on veut
regarder les colories on va laavir en
bleu en rose en jaune en vert et on va
la voir en noir ça sur les deux modèles
iPhone 15 iPhone 15 plus et puis après
le stockage 128 1119 € 256 1249 € et 512
1499 9 € voilà pour les coloris et pour
les tarifs et d'ailleurs pensez à venir
protéger vos iPhones avec les
protections de mon partenaire Rino
shield alors vous connaissez Rino shield
c'est un fabricant de protection premium
pour smartphone mais pas que puisque
vous les avez également pour les Apple
watch pour les airpods pour énormément
de produits bien évidemment je vous mets
le lien juste en bas dans la description
alors regardez parce que ils ont plein
de produits différents à commencer par
les solid suit que vous allez avoir de
différentes couleurs alors moi j'ai un
petit coup de cœur pour le bleu vous le
voyez j'aime bien le bleu du bleu du
bleu du bleu il y a du bleu partout
j'aime bien le bleu foncé le bleu clair
mais il y en a également pour tous les
goûts et ça c'est vach vachement bien ce
qui est génial c'est que c Sony suite on
peut venir les personnaliser comme j'ai
notamment ici sur mon iphone 15 pro max
avec une bonne création monsieur Greux
alors on pe aller très loin en terme de
personnalisation on peut venir également
personnaliser les boutons soit des
petits boutons noirs comme j'ai là moi
j'ai mis aussi un petit bouton vert ici
j'aime bien ça rappelle mon logo c'est
bien c'est sympa c'est joli merci
rinoield alors elle existe en noir mais
également en blanc comme ça on se parle
ici de coqu mono matériaux grâce à
l'utilisation de techniques novatrice et
d'ailleurs ce procédé les rend
facilement et intégralement recyclaable
tout en réduisant la quantité de matière
première nécessaire à la fabrication et
ils ont également une structure en
bouclier qui a un petit clin d'œil au
logo de Rino shield et chez rinohield
vous avez également d'autres protections
vous avez également les clear case alors
là j'en ai une qui est customisée mais
on peut l'avoir également toute
transparente si on le souhaite vous avez
aussi les modes Enix il y a également
des câbles et ça c'est vachement
intéressant puisque si vous recherchez
des câbles en usbc un petit peu longs et
bien vous pouvez les avoir ici shield
ils font 2 m vous voyez usbc usbc ça
c'est vachement bien mais vous avez
également des bracelets pour vos Apple
watch ça c'est très très cool également
très pratique en plus de ça ils ont une
puissance magnétique deux fois
supérieure au standard max safe qui fait
que je prends je pose vous voyez ça
tient problème et d'ailleurs je vous le
montre chez rinochi il y a également une
gourde et ce qui est génial en plus chez
rinochiill c'est qu'il y a énormément de
collaborations dans plein d'univers
différents alors il y a la NBA qu'on va
venir retrouver ici avec Miami il y a
également Philadelphie ici un petit
smiley si vous voulez du côté positif
sans oublier One Piece il y a énormément
de coqus sur One Piece celle-là aussi
qui est super jolie mais également Oliv
Tom voyez il y a également Marvel
Assassin's Creed France rugby van Gog
Museum le JP explorer winnie the poou
Disney League of Legends Snoopy bref il
y en a énormément pour tout le monde
quel que soit vos goûts vous trouverez
forcément une collaboration qui vous
plaît mais chér on trouve également des
cordons de téléphone des Dragon des grip
des protections d'écran ça c'est quand
même vachement important mais il y a
également toutes les protections qui
sont arrivées pour vos pixel 8 des
solides suites notamment en version
maxif pour profiter de tout l'écosystème
d'accessoire et pendant 48 he profitez
de 15 % de réduction avec le CODE Greux
23 pour venir acheter vos protections
dans les meilleures conditions une fois
de plus le lien est juste en bas en
description et merci à rinoshi d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo en quoi cet
iPhone 15 plus iPhone 15 iPhone 15 plus
tient davantage de l'iPhone 14 pro 14
pro max par rapport à un iPhone 15 pro
max et bien déjà de par sa structure ici
on a une structure en aluminium alors
que sur l'iPhone 15 pro max vous le
savez ils nous ont annoncer le titane
qui est bien qui est joli que j'adore
d'ailleurs allez voir ma vidéo comme ça
vous saurez tout sur ce modèle là et
bien non ici on reste en aluminium
soyons clair de vous à moi ça ne pose
aucun problème et ça va très bien ça
reste résistant ça marche sur le dos
c'est un dos en vert très bien mat qui
ne prend particulièrement pas de trace
de doigt et ça je dois reconnaître que
c'est quand même vachement bien donc
lorsqu'on est allergique aux traces de
doigts et qu'on veut garder son
smartphone sans coque de protection et
bien on peut venir le faire faire comme
ça ici sans problème à l'avant vous avez
également un grand écran ici 6,7 pouces
c'est le modèle plus sinon 6,1 ça je
vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure et bien
vous avez un très grand écran qui est
intéressant pourquoi parce que c'est du
céramic shield pareil résistant qui ne
prend pas particulièrement de trac de
doigt on peut venir l'utiliser d'un côté
de l'autre ça va c'est bien ça convient
donc ça c'est cool maintenant l'autre
truc qui est vraiment intéressant qu'a
fait Apple cette année pour venir se
différencier de son iPhone 14 14 plus de
l'année dernière et bien c'est
d'intégrer dynamic highine qu'ils ont
présenté l'année dernière qu'ils ont
introduit sur les iPhone 14 pro 14 pro
max qu'on retrouve cette année sur tous
les iPhones de 2023 et bien vous avez
dynamic Island alors je pas vous faire
un tour sur dynamic Island mais c'est
une intégration logicielle qui est
vraiment intéressante pour votre
chronomètre votre C votre ça votre
musique bref passons rapidement donc on
a ça ça c'est cool le truc par contre
que je vais avoir un peu au regret qui
nous rapproche vraiment des iPhone de
l'année dernière et bien c'est que vous
avez pas le bouton d'action qui était
introduit cette année sur les modèles
Pro vous avez votre petit bouton
classique silencieux sonnerie qu'on
retrouvait déjà sur les iPhones avant et
qu'on retrouve ici aussi alors il y a un
autre truc qu'on retrouve et qu'on avait
vous le voyez c'est qu'en fait lorsqu'il
est éteint comme ça il est éteint comme
vous n'avez pas de promotion le
promotion c'est quoi c'est votre taux de
rafraîchissement variable ici sur
l'iPhone 15 iPhone 15 plus vous avez
uniquement un taux de rafraîchissement
de 60 Hz 60 Hz à 1000 balles ça ça fait
raller quand même alors je sais que
c'est Apple c'est leur positionnement
ils veulent différencier la gamme normal
standard la gamme pro ou sur la gamme
pro et bien il vous met le promotion
c'est-à-dire que vous allez avoir ce
taux de rafraîchissement variable qui va
aller de 1 à 120 Hz une dalle ltpo 2.0
passons rapidement là-dessus ça veut
donc dire que sur votre iPhone 15 iPhone
15 plus vous êtes tout le temps à 60 Hz
lorsque vous jouez à des jeux lorsque
vous êtes en train de naviguer de
scroller 60 Hz lorsqu'on s'est habitué à
avoir du 120 Hz ça apporte un peu plus
de fluidité un peu plus de confort
visuel alors peut-être que si vous
n'avez jamais utilisé un écran 120 Hz
vous allez pas vraiment voir la
différenceant plus que cette dal ici
elle est super bien calibrée c'est
vraiment une très belle dalle il y a
rien à dire mais ça fait raller à 1000
balles qu'on est pas au moins du 90 Hz
que Apple aurait pu introduire non chez
eux c'est soit 60 Hz sur les 15 15 plus
soit jusqu'à 120 Hz sur les modèles pro
ça me fait quand même un peu raller vu
l'addition et comme bien évidemment vous
n'avez pas ce promotion vous n'avez pas
non plus de always on display
c'est-à-dire que votre écran ne va pas
en permanence venir afficher l'heure et
les dernières notifications alors vous
me dirit OK pour l'autonomie cé pas mal
ouais ça change pas vraiment grand-chose
un petit peu mais pas énormément puisque
votre écran n'est pas en capacité de
descendre jusqu'à 1 Hz pour venir
afficher une image par seconde ce qui
globalement ne consomme pas énormément
au niveau de l'autonomie et bien c'est
60 Hz donc c'est soit allumé soit éteint
et une fois de plus pour un smartphone à
peu près 1000 balles ça fait un peu
raller par rapport à ce qu'on trouve sur
un Android alors après ici on est chez
Apple Apple s'en fout complètement de ce
qui se passe chez Android mais bon c'est
vrai qu'on aurait pu aimer retrouver du
promotion cette année à minima 90 Hz à
minima à côté de ça faut quand même le
reconnaître cet écran est vraiment bien
et superbement bien calibré film séries
tout ce que vous voulez gaming vous en
profiterez réellement gaming à 60 Hz
uniquement autre point qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est un écran qui est
extrêmement lumineux lorsque vous allez
à l'extérieur ça va pousser énormément
vous lirez très bien même lorsque vous
avez le soleil sur votre écran c'est pas
ce qu' de plus confort mais croyez-moi
ça fonctionne vraiment bien ces iPhone
15 et 15 plus se rapproche des iPhone 14
pro et 14 pro max de l'année dernière et
notamment de par la puce à savoir que
sur le modèle de 2023 vous avez
exactement la même puce que dans le
modèle de 2022 au niveau des modèles
professionnels c'est la A16 bionicque
qui soyons clair même si c'est de la
génération précédente ira parfaitement
bien on a une puce très précise très
rapide très performante très bonne au
niveau de l'autonomie donc ici même si
c'est pas la dernière génération le taf
est fait le taf est vraiment bien fait
elle participe bien évidemment à
l'économie d'énergie et Apple nous
annonce 26 he me semble-t-il sur model
plus au niveau de l'autonomie en lecture
vidéo et 20h sur l'iPhone 15 bon ok pour
moi vous allez avoir ici une journée une
journée et demi d'autonomie à savoir que
sur un usage un peu modéré vous allez le
garder une journée et demi sans problème
après si vous avez besoin d'un peu plus
de performance si vous êtes davantage
dessus la journée vous allez faire
beaucoup de photos de CSA vous le
tiendrez une journée des fois un petit
peu moins pensez mener un bloc de charge
avec vous bloc de charge 20 W ici c'est
aussi un point qu'on peut avoir de
regret chez Apple bien que vous ayez un
smartphone performant la recharge
aujourd'hui reste aux alentours des 20 W
un petit peu plus si vous prenez un
chargeur du not marque ça je vous en ai
parlé au niveau de l'iPhone 15 pro max
pourquoi parce que vous avez l'arrivée
de l'usbc l'usbc sur tous les modèles ça
c'est l'Europe qui a obligé qu'à partir
de décembre 2024 et bien tous les
smartphones commercialisés en Europe
doivent avoir d'une recharge en usbc sur
quoi ils pourront plus être
commercialisés Apple a pris les devant a
mis l'USB c ds aujourd'hui d'ailleurs je
vous ai déjà fait une vidéo sur ma
chaîne youtube que vous pouvez aller
voir où je vous explique qu'est-ce qui
se passe au niveau de l'usbc la
différence entre l'USB 2 et l'USB3 ça on
en parle dans quelques instants et bien
évidemment je vous ai relayé des
informations de charge que m'a donné
dxark aller jeter un C de m vidéo de
l'iPhone 15 pro max vous allez tout voir
tout comprendre vous allez voir qu'ici
on peut réussir avec des blocs de charge
d'autres marques recharger aux alentours
des 26 27 W chez Apple c'est un petit
peu moins c'est du 20 W 22 W mais si
vous avez d'autres blocs de charge et
bien il y aura pas de dégradation de la
charge quel que soit le câble quel que
soit le bloc de charge donc ça c'est
plutôt intéressant ça c'est une très
très bonne nouvelle parce que et c'est
ça qui est intéressant que vous prenez
un iPhone 15 Pro 15 pro max un iPhone 15
15 plus et bien vous aurez dans les deux
cas à l'intérieur un câble en USB 2 à
différencier de ce qu'on peut avoir
maximum sur les iPhone 15 pro c'est de
l'USB 3 avec avec un débit jusqu'à 10
Gbit par seconde ici on jusqu'à 480 Mbit
par seconde donc tout ce qui va être
transfert extrêmement rapide monitoring
de vidéo lorsque vous tournez des films
et si et ça vous l'aurez sur les iPhone
15 pro mais pas sur l'iPhone 15 après
son nom l'indique très clairement le pro
des usages pro les iPhone 15 et 15 plus
des usages un peu plus pour monsieur et
madame tout le monde donc bon ici pour
moi il y a rien de surprenant et ça ne
pose absolument aucun problème le seul
truc qu'on peut venir un peu reprocher à
la puce qu'on a ici à la A16 Bionic
telle qu'elle est intégrée aujourd'hui
dans ce modèle c'est qu'il y a un petit
peu de chauff lorsque vous venez
vraiment pousser les usages on va sentir
que le smartphone chauffe un petit peu
alors ça c'est bien en hiver ça vous
réchauffera les doigts d'autant plus que
l'hiver arrive mais en période d'été
c'est pas ouf à savoir également que sur
la charge vous avez une compatibilité en
recharge sans fil max safe 15 W et si
vous prenez un chargeur QI vous êtes
jusqu'à 7,5 W maximum l'autre sujet qui
nous intéresse ici c'est toute la partie
photo et ça c'est vraiment super
intéressant vous le voyez la différence
que vous avez entre les iPhone 15 15
plus et les modèles professionnel et
bien sur les modèles Pro vous avez trois
capteurs sur les 15 15 plus vous avez
deux capteurs en fait ce qui va manquer
à l'appel c'est le le téléobjectif alors
c'est assez marrant parce qu'Apple nous
marque sur son site qu'il y a un
téléobjectif pour vous en rendre compte
il faut descendre au niveau de la fiche
alors là on descend aller dans les
caractéristiques et vous allez voir
qu'il y a un truc qui est pas forcément
vrai au niveau de l'appareil photo
appareil photo principal 48 mégapixel ça
c'est vachement bien parce que ça c'est
hérité des iPhone 14 pro de l'année
dernière et on regarde le résultat dans
quelques instants d'autant plus que
entre cette année l'iPhone 15 15 plus et
l'iPhone 15 Pro 15 pro max et bien vous
avez Capt 40 tu mégapixel partout donc
ça c'est super cool mais là où je suis
pas d'accord c'est qu' vous marque
objectif principal 48 objectif ultra
grand tle 12 les objectifs 2 x 12 c'est
faux c'est totalement faux et là il vous
le marque zoom optique arrière x 2
amplitude du zoom optique x 4 soyons
clair ici il y a pas de zoom optique
c'est un zoom numérique pourquoi
qu'est-ce qui se passe et bien vous avez
un grand capteur de 48 mégapixel
qu'est-ce qu'il vont venir faire en
disant ben on vient zoomer optiquement
c'est-à-dire que sur ce 48 mégapixel
lorsqu'ils veulent faire ce zoom ils
viennent récupérer ce que vous avez au
centre de l'image donc on repasse sur un
24 mégapixel en ayant fait un espèce de
zoom de crop dans l'image vous vous
retrouvez avec un 24 mgapixel zoomé et
on peut aller plus loin il vous marque
c'est pour ça qu'il vous le marque
amplitude du zoom optique x 4 vous
passez sur ce qui s'appelleront le X 2
on passe en 24 mégapixel ça c'est le X 2
et on peut rescendre en 12 mgapixel
c'est ce qu'ils appelleront le X 4 mais
en réalité vous venez zoomer dans votre
image en dégradant pas la qualité cert
parce que vous venez zoomer au centre de
l'image avec un 24 mégapixel en X 2 et
un 12 mégapixel en X 4 mais en réalité
c'est pas du tout du zoom optique donc
quand on écrit zoom optique arrière x 4
c'est faux c'est un zoom numérique si on
veut un zoom optique aujourd'hui chez
Apple on va sur les modèles Pro vous
avez un vrai téléobjectif là vous avez
un zoom optique dès lors qu'on vient
croper sur un capteur de 48 mégapixel
c'est un zoom numérique et non pas un
zoom optique donc là je suis pas
d'accord avec vous Apple alors vous
allez reconnaître des prises de vue
qu'on a fait lors du test de l'iPhone 15
pro max elles ont été shooté exactement
au même moment dans les mêmes conditions
donc ça ça ass intéressant alors
regardez si vous regardez comme ça alors
là les conditions sont un peu
compliquées avec effectivement on le
voit ce petit néon même s'il y a une
lumière derrière bon globalement dans
l'ensemble le taf eff fait grand angle
ultra grand angle on peut venir zoomer
un petit peu c'est plutôt pas mal on
manque de piquer quand même au niveau de
l'ultra grand angle on le voit ici
lorsque vous vous rapprochez sur le
grand angle tout de suite beaucoup mieux
on peut venir zoomer un peu globalement
faut-il pas trop loin parce que c'est
pas ouf pareil la regarder ici au niveau
des couleurs bon je vous montre un peu
au niveau des poivrons ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est que les couleurs sont
rendu assez naturel le rouge est bien
rouge le vert est bien vert et le jaune
est bien jaune vous l'avez compris en
venant zoomer on une petite différence
ici de colorimétrie pourtant c'est le
même capteur c'est assez marrant voyez
on va é de bien trop près l'ultra grand
angle manque de piquer une fois de plus
on le voit vraiment ici au niveau des
feuilles le grand angle qui fait le taf
après ça reste assez naturel il faut pas
avoir tendance à sursaturer comme ce
qu'on peut retrouver chez Samsung c'est
clair c'est bien c'est net d'ailleurs je
vous avais fait une vidéo où je viens
mettre en face l'iPhone 15 pro max et le
Galaxy S23 ultra aller jeter un coup
d'œil c'est intéressant pour voir
vraiment le travail d'un côté de Samsung
en face du travail d'Apple très très
intéressant voyez ici c'est net on a du
détail c'est clair il y a une très bonne
gestion de la lumière ce smartphone
soyons clair est un excellent photophone
même en contrejour ça fonctionne très
très bien on évite de venir pousser le
zoom trop loin parce que globalement il
va moins y arriver mais dans l'ensemble
vous sortirez quand même de très bons
clichés ici pas de mauvaise nouvelle
alors attention une des différences que
vous avez également par rapport au
modèle professionnel c'est que vous
n'avez pas de macro ici vous allez venir
zoomer numériquement mais il y a pas de
macro dans ces smartphonese c'est très
joli sur un contrejour ça marche bien
attention ici hop voyez un peu de bazar
à droite à gauche mais globalement le
taf fait du détail ça c'est quand même
vachement bien donc bon pour moi cet
iPhone reste quand même excellent en
terme de photo on est dans le haut du
panier on est dans le très haut de gamme
je vous passe quelques photos voyez
conditions comme ça en faible luminosité
ça marche il a un peu plus de mal au
niveau du mouvement là où l'iPhone 15
pro Max était meilleur et venait plus
s'arrêter sur le mouvement que lui c'est
un peu un peu moins bon je sais pas
pourquoi là-dessus des photos comme ça
qui sont aussi très bonnes le mode
portrait qui fonctionne très très bien
voyez au niveau des cheveux tous les
côtés ça fonctionne bien donc ici pour
moi il y a rien à redire et lorsqu'on
arrive condition avec un peu moins de
lumière c'est pas foufou voà et la nuit
c'est pareil bon voilà condition de
faible luminosité ça marche il s'en sort
il s'en sort autre nouveauté par rapport
à ce qu'on avait avant c'est qu'avant on
avait le Smart hdr4 on a le Smart hdr5
bon ok nouvelle génération qui sont
venus intégrer également c'est iPhone 15
et 15 plus à noter que à la différence
de ce que vous avez sur les modèles Pro
vous n'avez pas de portrait en mode nuit
et vous vous n'avez pas non plus d'Apple
pro RW donc ici on va pas venir shooter
en r en r on comprend parce qu'on va
plus l'attendre du côté des
professionnels ici c'est pas le cas
Apple s'adresse plus à tout un chacun
plutôt qu'au pro si on veut venir
shooter en Apple pro on va aller sur
l'iPhone 15 Pro 15 pro max de la même
manière lors vous allez faire de la
vidéo vous pourrez pas shooter en log
pas de flat c'est réservé au modèle
professionnel et pas non plus ici
également d'Apple ProRes bon on comprend
également positionnement d'Apple
là-dessus sur la vidéo aussi vous allez
voir alors soyons clair pour moi c'est
quand même vachement bien si vous êtes
sur le 48 mgapixel si vous VZ pas zoomer
si vous venez zoomer vous allez voir
qu'on va venir se dégrader en qualité
bon mis à part Robin qui nous fait truc
super bien là avec un peu moins de
luminosité hop vous allez voir il va
arriver là globalement c'est pas mauvais
on évite de venir zoomer parce que dès
qu'on vient zoomer tout de suite on
vient dégrader la qualité c'est pas ouf
voyez tout le bruit numérique qu'il y a
lorsque on vient filmer en ayant trop
zoomé vraiment je le recommande pas
condition ici avec un petit feu de bois
comme sur le le Modelle pro ici
globalement pas grand chose à vous dire
de plus ça fonctionne plutôt pas mal
donc bon ici au niveau de la vidéo pas
de mauvaise surprise on peut venir
filmer bien évidemment en 4K 60 imag par
seconde bref on a quelque chose qui est
très très très bien c'est un excellent
smartphone alors vous savez depuis
l'iPhone 11 Apple a vraiment mis la
barre beaucoup plus haute au niveau de
la captation vidéo c'est vraiment bien
c'est bien stabilisé ils améliore tout
le temps donc si vous voulez un
excellent smartphone pour venir filmer
vous le prenez à la main comme ça sans
stabilisateur sans rien ça marche
vraiment super bien et c'est un
excellent smartphone pour ça je l'ai
fait plein de fois dans plein de
conditions j'ai toujours été vraiment
surpris par le résultat donc on voit
qu'il est très polyvalent en photo il
est moins polyvalent que les modèles pro
parce qu'on a pas cé l'objectif mais
globalement pour venir immortaliser des
photos avec le 48 mégapixel ça va bien
on voit qu'on manque un peu de piquet au
niveau de l'ultra grand angle mais bon
c'est un ultra grand angle rien de
surprenant ici ça marche donc pour moi
la partie photo est au rendez-vous alors
on a également toutes les techn que nous
propose Apple et qu'on vient retrouver
la détection des accidents le SOS
d'urgence par satellite on est bien
évidemment certifié IP68 c'est la
moindre des choses ici on a Apple pay
alors le truc qui me fait un peu raller
que j'étais content de retrouver sur le
modèle Pro cette année et bien c'est le
fait d'avoir du Wii 6e je trouve ça
dommage qu'il viennent pas mettre dans
les iPhone 15 et 15 plus du Wii 6e on
doit rester en Wii 6 une fois de plus
sur des smartphones à plus de 1000
balles je trouve ça vraiment dommage à
côté de ça vous retrouvez de l'ultra
wide band de 2è génération ok AIRTAG
soyons clair il y a pas non plus la
techn qui est intégrée qu'on peut avoir
dans les modèles pro mais pas ici vous
voyez quand même une petite différence
donc on est vraiment entre d'un côté les
iPhone 14 pro de l'autre côté l'iPhone
15 il y a une vraie différence avec ces
deux modèles c'est normal Apple doit
segmenter les gammes c'est bien que moi
je me pose une question je me dis
pourquoi est-ce qu'en fait j'irais pas
acheter plutôt un iPhone 14 pro plutôt
qu'un iPhone 15 on peut mettre en face
l'iPhone 15 l'iPhone 14 pro ou alors
l'iPhone 15 plus et l'iPhone 14 pro max
voyons clair l'iPhone 14 pro max rest
quand même très cher et c'est d'ailleurs
un des gros avantages d'Apple
c'est-à-dire ce qu'on appellera la
valeur résiduelle à savoir qu'un
smartphone que vous avez acheté année
dernière ici un iPhone 14 pro max garde
un tarif élevé donc lorsque vous voulez
le revendre 1 an 2 ans après vous perdez
pas beaucoup d'argent un peu mais vous
en tirez toujours un bon prix à la
différence de beaucoup de smartphones
sur Android tout de suite les tarifs
vont dégringoler et 6 mois après c'est
pas la même et un an après vous aurez
perdu quand même beaucoup d'argent donc
des fois on peut se dire que venir
acheter un smartphone d'Apple c'est
plutôt un bon plan parce que l'argent
que vous mettez vous le perdez pas
complètement vous en récupérez toujours
une partie soit pour le renouveler quand
il sera le moment de venir le renouveler
soit lorsque vous désirez de le revendre
et puis j'en sais rien bon racheter un
smartphone sur Android à vous de voir à
vous de voir moi en tout cas ce que je
vois c'est que cette iPhone 15 plus je
peux venir le recommander sans aucun
problème iPhone 15 iPhone 15 plus sont
très bien il y a pour moi certains
points où je Râ et je vous l'ai dit
parce que que des iPhones a quasiment
1000 balles soit un peu plus specké il
faut néanmoins qu'Apple Vienne
différencier ses gammes ils le font sur
plein de points différents au niveau du
processeur Wii 6 Wii 6 et compagnie bref
maintenant posez-vous la question et
regardez je suis allé jeter un petit
coup d'œil voyez voyez là sur le site
d'Apple quand je vois qu'un iPhone 15
plus plus je commence à 1119 € et
lorsque je vais par exemple sur la Fnac
et je VO un iPhone 14 pro alors en 128
soyons clair mais ici aussi je suis à
128 et bien je suis à 1129 € c'estàd que
j'ai 10 € d'écart pour avoir certes un
modèle de l'année dernière mais avec
vrai téléobjectif avec exactement la
même puce à l'intérieur alors certes
recharge en Lightning pas en usbc bon
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est très grave
je ne suis pas convaincu mais o j'aurai
un bloc photo qui sera bien meilleur
avec déjà dynamic Island ici à
l'intérieur où j'aurais plus d'options
pour venir filmer ici en vidéo plus
d'options pour venir shooter en photo à
quasiment le même prix donc vous voyez
la question se pose donc si vous avez un
budget de 1119 € peut-être que ça vaut
le coup de rajouter 10 € de partir
certes sur un modèle de l'année dernière
mais un modèle Pro qui en fera plus que
votre iPhone 15 plus allez savoir
d'ailleurs dites-moi ce que vous en
pensez en bas dans les commentaires et
je vous invite également à venir
regarder ma vidéo où je viens comparer
en photo l'iPhone 15 pro max et le
Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra vous allez voir
le parti pris est vraiment différent au
niveaux de la photo vraiment la vidéo
est là allez jeter un œil c'est super
intéressant